and this morning there's explosive new
information about an investigation of
republican congressman matt gates
the new york times reports the outspoken
defender former president donald trump
is suspected
of paying cash and using drugs and
sexual encounters with women
senior investigative correspondent
katherine herrich is following this
investigation catherine
boy the more you hear about this the
more bizarre
and the worst it seems for mr gates well
gail good morning according to the times
the encounters with the women took place
in 2019 and 2020. investigators believe
it was one of gates's associates former
county tax collector joel greenberg
who recruited multiple women online and
introduced them to the congressman
the time sources alleged gates used the
drug ecstasy
before having sex and the paper said it
reviewed receipts
showing gates and greenberg's payments
to one of the women
the alleged transactions could put gates
in legal jeopardy if authorities find
he used force fraud or coercion to have
sex
in a statement to the times gates office
said matt gates refutes
all the disgusting allegations
completely an attorney for greenberg
who faces separate charges for child sex
trafficking and other crimes
declined to comment to the times the new
details come as the justice department
is also looking into whether gates
had a sexual relationship with a
17-year-old
and paid for her to travel across state
lines with him potentially violating
sex trafficking laws in addition what we
understand is that the congressman has
denied these allegations
and no charges have been filed for
having a relationship with a minor the
florida lawmaker has sought
to paint these allegations as part of an
extortion scheme
against him and his family adriana some
disturbing allegations catherine thank
you